of course pressure on nato to do more is
growing especially on u.s president joe
biden a group of u.s senators has
traveled to poland demanding biden green
light the transfer of polish fighter
jets to ukraine but as jennifer johnson
reports there are still no plans to take
that step due to fears of escalating the
conflict
as russia's military forces ahead trying
to destroy ukraine city by city calls
are growing louder for the u.s and nato
to do anything to make it stop before
it's too late that includes getting
poland's big fighter jets into ukraine a
deal president joe biden will only
support if the u.s isn't involved
president putin and his generals are
testing the resolve of the nato alliance
so we need to see all of our member
nations come together show strength a
group of u.s senators is in poland
meeting with military leaders trying to
find solutions to stop russian president
vladimir putin other world leaders are
echoing their concerns warning if putin
succeeds this war won't be his last the
end of freedom in ukraine will mean the
extinction of any hope of freedom in
georgia and then boulder but it will
mean the beginning of a new age of
intimidation across the whole of eastern
europe president biden heads to brussels
this week for a nato summit on new
defense and economic strategies to
pressure putin the u.s has sent two
billion dollars in military assistance
to ukraine since biden took office a
billion alone last week after president
vladimir zelinsky made an impassioned
plea to congress a top ranking democrat
hence more firepower is coming there are
other ways for us to provide
surface-to-air missiles and air defenses
that will keep
the russians at bay and would not
jeopardize expanding this into world war
three or even worse
top u.s military leaders see russia
targeting more civilians and claiming it
has used hypersonic missiles at least
twice in ukraine as indications putin's
military is struggling the reason that
he's resorting to
using these types of weapons is because
he's trying to re-establish some
momentum is he running low on precision
precision guided munitions
does he have like complete confidence in
his ability to
the ability of his troops but putin's
ability to control the airspace over
ukraine remains a top concern
even as nato and many world leaders
reject repeated pleas for a no-fly zone
over the country
jennifer johnson global news washington